so
wären aber das sind maximal drei wochen
rückfällig wurden die psychische
abhängigkeit
der reportage reddig mitglied wo
medikament ritalin missbrauch zu
probieren damit ihre leistung zu pushen
oder deal mit tabletten
also je nach dem advents wodurch so doch
als sicherer ohne ritalin aber aus
gefährlich auf mich hört wenn die
teilnehmer ritalin hätte aufputschende
wirkung von legalen guckst du missbrauch
vor dem etikett ali folge habe von
psychischen abhängigkeit über angst
plötzlich
das ist schlecht für das herz
wo er
im konsum führer der franco ära
[Musik]
der 18 jährige täterin und zwar mehr
schlaf krankheit diagnostiziert dann ist
mit persönlichem ritalin macht
eigentlich immer dann wenn wir trotz
minimaler medikamentenentwickler wach
bleiben und zum beispiel beim auslassen
wie sie aus als wie es mitbekommen was
dort steht würde ich sozusagen von
möglichkeit nicht gedanken und einfach
aufgehört als hat die
schulhof und so hofft kasper nach der
hüft augen ihres petko und da bleibt man
einfach ab und als üblich aus zumal
italiens größter und das ritterleben
machen sozusagen mit körper und geist
der wirkstoff methylphenidat wie adhs
medikamente wie ritalin ist ist
amphetamin anhalt zum aufputschen die
wirklich ähnlich wie guckt einfach ohne
euphorische h effekt bei dem das ritalin
das nur im ausland ribéry tut ihm
wirklich ihre leistung zu pushen
doping oder neuro enhancement ob das
überhaupt bis bringt kleine reportage im
umfeld kennen aber zum beispiel einige
wo genau seine tabletten schlucken oder
geschluckt hat zum lehrer
einige stoffe bekannt informiert sie
wurde anonym blieben mit ihren pc
soft hey hauptsache zum trainer für tags
lassen und verarbeiten vor allem ihre
seminararbeiten wird denn nicht auch
ohne die berlin co doch ist sicher ohne
ritalin aber auf
mich hört sich zieht wenn ritalin
sozusagen innerhalb von einem tag denn
so viel
ist
klar wieso nimmt ist ja nichts zu
schaffen
ob jetzt studium oder schaffen eigenen
haus beliefern sie weit weg von ritalin
erachte wirkung gehabt extrem zäh und
sehr antisozial also kontakt mit dem
menschen sehr schnell nach pcs
überfordert wenn es hinter liefert
da sind sie meistens erleide bibliothek
mit mini büro und wird die technik steht
vor allem die frage ob ihre den
niedergang krieg aber es gibt klar ist
es nicht wenn es so reagiert jetzt viel
koffein ego optisch ab dadurch das ist
in tallinn aus sicherer quelle weiß dass
es super ist mir die kritisch mache ich
mir mit allzu großen gedanken
dass
ich mit keiner es ist übrigens offenes
geheimnis
denn wirklich darüber reden jeder weiß
ganz genau also ist missbrauch und
richten legal als von dem wir mit mal
vor dass eva lüke twitter ob berlin
verkaufen die erfahrung machen offenbar
andere wo ritalin verzagtheit und einige
schrieben sie wirklich verkaufen um
ranghohe
das ganze 100
studierende hoffen und da seid ich kenne
viele jugendliche in meinem alter ich
bin 16 die italiener regelmäßig nehmen
oder zumindest einmal konsumiert haben
will bekommen verschrieben okay es wird
aber auch oft weitergegeben und verkauft
unter simon doch genau das aber mit dem
simon face time hypoport anonym blieb
[Musik]
hallo
ich sage schon mal ritalin liegt
also die was wissen dass sie an oder das
für andere nervös sind ja der fragen
noch höher lagen schauen wir sollten sie
für das ritalin je nachdem kann man so
10 franken oder so
also je nach dem advanced durch so werde
jetzt für eine da bleibt den fans
gestoppt also sich ja auch nicht so dass
man immer für 20 kann verkäufer zum
wirklich mich 200 alina kostete bis über
60 franken
oder ja wenn er nachts vorteil so groß
sind denken sie schon dass es sich lohnt
sich schon mal gedanken gemacht dass du
für antwort die die eigentlich hätte das
medikamente sind erlaubt
ja also jetzt ohne gegenwehr schlechtes
gewissen oder so vor deinem land ihr
eigentlich niemand auf der straße so
dass die fans nicht so schlimm so aller
vans liegt mit adhs oder ads
verschrieben irgend denn soviel ich so
es kann ja gar nicht so schlimm sie dass
ihm einfach auf 10 tabletten frauen aber
kannte ich von der bisher größte
internationale studie zu neuen hensmann
zeigt dass fast hälfte vor der 100
befragten ritalin und co illegal von
bekannten würde warum also hat die
patrizia angefangen wo sich bei mir
gemeldet hat zu ihrer mutter unterwegs
raus zu lassen
london/berlin kino wie adhs
diagnostiziert nicht gemanagte 34 jahre
ist es aber relativ dass ein roter knopf
und der italiener vom ist bucher und
eben dosis massiver
vorgestoßen
es ist erst mal nicht genau wo ich
bin und das ist für meine kollegen und
hat das danach
normal ich habe mich konzentriere ich
bin so soziale situationen verbessert
sich eine zur trägheit und so hat es
denn eigentlich in lauf genommen nach
der erfahrung mit ritalin hätte sich auf
der slow up klare und 50 jahre zurück
was ist eigentlich so die maxime autos
ist sie also hoffentlich das ganze
nochmals sie somit ries konzertes
anfangen und dann plötzlich ein punkt
will kann heißen
quellen entnommene und nach
habe das gefühl dass ich mit klug ist
ohne knöpfe formen und ja das ist den
deal bis 170 180
280 milligramm maximale tagesdosis für
erwachsene mensch für möglich dass sie
so ins stadion oder woran hätte das
wirklich viel problem gelöst das macht
wie so viel besser also
gegangen und der nach elvis wichtigste
moment
das wort natur macht dass man das gut
gemacht und nachher ist es der bachelors
sie und ihre
mitstreiter eigentlich das ist wirklich
unschön kann also macht die at t stiege
abklärung und ich bin halt wirklich
zügig angegangen und
weil ich wünsche mir einfach sagen ich
will das und ich will das einfach offen
eine legale wartet nicht irgendwie mir
sorgen und ich habe natürlich die frage
bei und alles nach so ausgefüllt
das ist
das risiko dass
[Musik]
ich habe das immer gewünscht dass ich so
erfolgreich dass ich das alles im griff
haben dass ich wie immer die besten
und berlin hat mir
das team im kopf sagt sie ich bin nur
knapp und ich bin nur erfolgreich und
gut
patricia fahrt zu ihrem ehemaligen
psychiater jahre lang hat ihre ritalin
geschrieben ohne zu merken dass ihre
konsum über bord und sie in abhängigkeit
recherche war italien nimmt ohne dass es
medizinisch nötig ist wird abhängig von
kimi patricia field radio
es ist nicht so schlimm wie nie so
intensiv psycho oder das ist wirklich
mich lappens und weg machten oder
psychisch extrem darunter
haben punkte klettern wollte wissen wie
es mit ritalin ist es forschung für tag
genau zwei jahre sieht barclays letzten
ritalin knoten vermeintlichen tag hätte
sie damit aufgehört
haben
was ist passiert
ich
habe ein schlechtes spiel weg gegangen
ist ein kreislaufzusammenbruch und
danach bin ich zum arzt und nach einer
hand sie alles angeguckt und so dass auf
24 stunden ekg das hat mir acht
geschäfte also dass alles aufgeklärt
haben dann nehme ich gemerkt habe es ist
muss einfach jetzt andere
mit patricia mit ihrem ehemaligen
psychiater über ihre missbrauch
rhein-sieg-kreis ritalin nimmt und auf
ordner ist dino mattick gang führt die
neue ration ritalin gehabt sollen
mögliche gespräche zwischen psychiater
und er hat praktisch nie so hat er
offenbar bis 4 um missbrauch mit warum
auch immer wieder mehr ritalin wo
das doch ein foul
aber
der bezirk für ist kann ich mir dann
auch eine chance krachen ich glaube
darum hätte es also schwierig macht wie
viel
das oder wie groß der abstand beste sie
zum bieten normale dosis sie und da darf
man natürlich was man ja nichts machen
weil man ritalin nimmt zu pausen gemacht
vor zwei wochen noch zwei
wochen ist mir eigentlich immer so gut
ging ja weil ich habe für freaks 7 und
weil ich mich selber 7
weil ich glücklich bin ich auch eine
bessere freunde kollegen und
trotzdem
mit dem leistungsrichter gut leisten und
so
oder und darum bin ich immer wieder
zurückgegangen trauen sich aber auch
immer weniger angst weil ich habe ihr so
die glückliche person dann halt jemand
hinter mir
patricia verzögerungen aber wirklich
viele sind untypisch wie ritalin und
keine sauberen doch die iren heimliches
extremismus sagen
er sagt die letzten zwei drei jahren
drei bis vier stunden schlafe der nacht
den
appetitlosigkeit
sagte sido wenn er nicht so liebevoll
sie überhaupt nicht also ich bin sicher
das desinteresse
romanische und generell mehr familien
und gründer und halt einfach nur das
ist
mir dank so durch sterben
das alles ist aber das so und jetzt
jetzt bin ich so sensibel auf das auch
ich glaube ich könnte aber wenn ich mal
höhere entscheiden amerikaner ich könnte
es nicht ich kann mein körper grenzen
it-händler effektive heidfelds west
anstoßen basiert und kommen wir also
nachdem patrice als ritalin endgültig
abgesetzt hat sie plötzlich eine
panikattacke zu hören die hier besonders
an gemacht und bot ohne humor haben sie
oft viele neue psychiaterin und
verhaltenstherapie gemacht zu ihrem
vorherigen psychiatrie gott ist groß sie
im zirkus passiert ist
[Musik]
aber jetzt
im gespräch die werte aber zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt noch gespräche führen
in der zwischenzeit martin überbreite
missbrauch von ritalin und co die bisher
größte internationale studie zum thema
zeigt dass sie 15 untersuchten
industrieland der missbrauch von
medikamenten von 2015 bis 2017 extrem zu
heute im schnitt hat sagte
konsumforscher vertrieb acht andere
studie zeigt dass die schweiz 4,1
prozent vor der studierenden mindestens
so einiges zu ritalin und co
kräftig steigern der studie ich habe
schon fast sagen ich würde aber gleich
noch wissen wir gut eigne sich ritalin
und co überhaupt
geredet um mit zwei experten
schweizerischen fachgesellschaft für
adhs das ist ja eine ganz spannende
frage
wie ist es bei gesunden
da hat sich jetzt
auf dauer mithalten aber die
leistungsfähigkeit nimmt halt auf dauer
nichts
aber ob es dann wirklich auf dauer
vielleicht in der kurzfristigen phase
aber das auf dauer gut ist und ob die
leistung dann über das gesamte studium
dadurch besser wird möchte ich streng
bezweifeln und für mich ist extrem
wichtig nicht einfach ich gebe ihnen
jetzt hier malt ab die ritalin schachtel
sondern ich muss die patientinnen und
patienten begleiten das ist
psychotherapeut tisch das ist eigentlich
so ein rundum paket das sich dann halt
wie immer in der medizin hat auch
individuell anpassen müssen es gibt
nicht die therapie
manche brauchen auch gar keine
freiheiten das therapierbar coaching das
ist so wichtig was wir natürlich
manchmal haben ist dass patienten sagen
das medikament funktioniert so gut ich
will gar keine begleitende
psychotherapie machen zb ein 16-jähriger
der sagt ich möchte gar nicht sondern dr
kupfer schlägt ihn und da immer meine
probleme reden aber das medikament
nämlich doch ganz gerne weil ich merke
es hilft mir das ist dann natürlich eine
entscheidung des patienten und der
familie die empfehlung wäre immer auch
etwas anderes außer medikamenten zu
machen ich verlange dann auch die
patienten irgendwann mal wieder zu sehen
selbst wenn sie gut eingestellt sind und
wenn es nur um die nebenwirkungen geht
da muss man wirklich sicher sein das
kann ja doch mal eine blutdruck
steigerung kommen oder doch mal auch
irgendetwas am herzen sein wenn man es
dann nach und nach steigert muss man
natürlich auch sich überlegen liegt denn
überhaupt nach der heiß vor weil das ist
ja gerade spannend dass die meisten
menschen mit adhs die dann auf so
bilanzjahres bund ihren ja eben gerade
nicht süchtig davon werden letztendlich
ganz auszuschließen ist natürlich selbst
bei der richtigen diagnose eine
suchtentwicklung natürlich nicht experte
sei genauso wichtig blitz begleitete wo
die talente schübe räume für patricia
ist das aber nicht passiert ich frage
mich ob ihre italien missbrauch der das
habt ihr instrumente werden doch werden
diese nötige gespritzt wird der
ehemalige boykott ist ja genau das
aussprach
wenn ich jetzt all die patienten die mit
medikamenten behandelt werden wegen adhs
auch noch in einer therapie unterbringen
wollte also einer unglaublichen
geschweige denn selber machen dann hätte
ich sämtliche therapeuten der großregion
folge nagel mit patienten das ist die
realität in der
versorgungssituation als meine devise
das spreche ich jetzt mal für mich
psychotherapie ist sinnvoll notwendig
wenn zwei erkrankungen davon gibt es
genug
dass man
versucht ist
auch die körperliche abhängigkeit
sie hatten ja sogar die fähigkeit dann
tagelang
medikamente nicht zu nehmen um ist für
die spitzen oder die auf den
spitzenleistungen dann abzurufen aber es
waren missbrauchs von
missbräuchliche einnahme
ich habe gemerkt dass bis zum 11 12 wie
ist es einfach gegangen und am
nachmittag ist es den kredit um zu einem
volk ich bin ich unterwegs und habe ich
so ein tunnel
sowie einfach aus ist und ich kann mich
denn da wissen immer mehr richtig
bewegen
wenn sie schon auf dem quasi optimum
ihre
gehirnleistung sind können sie durch ein
stimulans die wirkung oder ihr gehirn
nicht zum super brain machen aber wenn
das optimum überschritten wird auch mit
der dosis überschritten wird dann wird
zum beispiel die konzentration
schlechter die unruhe wird höher die
emotionale labilität wird höher und ich
befürchte das sind sie auch in eine
falle getappt die eigentliche
problematik von patricia sind rita links
sie sondern ihre verlangen nach
selbstoptimierung und beschäftigt das
phänomen oder drk später beobachtet
die gesellschaft
jetzt noch sprich
man sage ich auch sehr interessant von
der ces verstehen und ich ausspannen
konnte aber selbst das ist jene dass
sucht geht sondern dass es im missbrauch
sehe schon dass job ist wo
die beste weil ich finde es extrem
stark und
hat das ist mir so lang hat und dass er
wie gesagt das hätte mir eine kurve wenn
ich nicht irgendeine form von ads oder
adhs haben
also schon erschreckend was meine kamera
auslöser wenn es falsch verwendet chance
für moser italien nimmt christian stör
ihre missbrauch halten bloß wurde mit
mir ca außerdem leistet und der ist
eigentlich dass ritalin beste boden
gesetzt mit der ums was es zuvor
vorgemacht mit ritalin und kurze
leistungssteigerung
juni kommentar antwortet ist vergessen
und
studienkollegen von ihm teilt